[Applause]
all right
happy tuesday everyone
so recently a violent sex fiend named
daryl brooks had been released from jail
after posting a minimal bond for
punching the mother of his child and
then trying to run her over
now you'd think this guy who had
outstanding warrants wouldn't have been
let out much less allowed back in the
same damn car he used to run over a
human being but of course he was and
then he drove his suv into a crowd of
people in a parade killed a bunch of
them and kept on going i'm guessing he
wasn't heading to a father of the year
ceremony
so how would you describe that nbc
called it a crash which is like calling
joy behar chatty i guess i guess fender
bender was too wordy
quote authorities have said that brooks
fled the scene of a domestic disturbance
just before the crash
it isn't clear if he has another lawyer
for the charges related to sunday's
crash
so just a crash guys act of god an
honest mistake you know brooks was
probably on his way to help victims of
white supremacy and those dead white
people were just trying to stop him
sorry i was channeling msnbc for a
minute there
but it's stories like these that show
you how the media works they use the
lens of race on every story until the
colors change and that's because the
lens of race only curves in one
direction which makes one think that
maybe the lens shouldn't be used at all
because when a story like this appears
involving a black suspect they turn the
race filter off which shows you that
they don't report reality they only
create it when it suits them
cnn spends more time in wonderland than
alice with chris cuomo and don lemon as
tweedledee and tweedle dumber
this story won't flood the airwaves like
so many stories that led to riots and
death i mean who's going to protest for
the people who suffered at the hands of
this evil violent man who will make
murals for his victims or name streets
after them see that just won't work
today remember what cnn said just days
before there's nothing more frightening
than an angry white man
so pity for cnn that brooks is black
with a long criminal history but maybe
the press can spin this into a he's a
white supremacist i mean black folks can
be white supremacists too according to
the press just ask grand cyclops larry
elder
can you imagine jeff zucker's
disappointment when he found the driver
was black i mean how am i going to pay
for that new house on the vineyard or
the one on saint barts
so what do you do when the narrative
doesn't fit well let's ask mary lemanski
the illinois democrat was the social
media director for the democrats in
dupage county
but not anymore after she called the
murderous rampage karma for rittenhouse
according to her karma's a [ __ ] but
according to me so is she
lemanski also claims she's a comedian
that works with second city improv and
with material that bad she could
definitely write for kimmel
meanwhile the squad keeps pushing for
abolishing federal prisons and excessive
bail but to them excessive bail is any
bail at all it's crazy pushing for more
bail reform the same day a felon kills
five people while out on bail that's
like pushing for more wuhan labs after a
covet outbreak
maybe it's me but i'm thinking maybe
bale should be higher than hunter biden
on a trip to peru
and maybe certain maniacs shouldn't be
bailed out at all on monday aoc demanded
answers on excessive bail aoc loves
demanding answers like which designer
dressed to wear to a gala or how to fake
cry without cutting onions it's the
serious question she always gets wrong
apparently she has not walked the
streets of nyc lately where violent
criminals are in and out of jail like
brian stelter's in and out of
baskin-robbins
she's good though she has more security
than the pope running out at night for a
pack of smokes what she really needs
around her is a straight jacket and a
padded room meanwhile her even dumber
cohort rashida to leave tried to explain
her support for a law that would empty
prisons it's called the breathe act and
if it passes there will be a lot of
innocent people who no longer breathe
everyone's like oh my god we're gonna
just release everybody that's not
yeah but did you see how many people are
mentally ill that are in prison right
now no i know it but the act that you
endorsed actually says release everyone
but in ten years but think about it who
are releasing if they were like human
traffickers oh i know child sex your
proposal is so sweepy it does it does
release everyone and what i'm trying to
say within 10 years and obviously
there's a process of looking at how can
we get away from mass incarceration
and move towards care for what
well at least she's not smug
wow she makes the cast of the view look
like rocket scientists
so remember brooks killed a bunch of
people after being set free weeks ago
that's a consequence of the squad's
beliefs resentment fanaticism a lust to
punish anyone who doesn't think like
they do but we cannot forget the
milwaukee d.a john chisholm who
relentlessly pushed cash bail reform
because he says it criminalizes poverty
in a 2007 interview he said is there
going to be an individual that i divert
or i put into a treatment program is
going to go out and kill somebody
you bet
guaranteed it's guaranteed to happen
it does not invalidate the overall
approach
so there you go
the fact that criminals take innocent
lives will not invalidate their beliefs
in letting these criminals out the
consequences of their actions can't even
change their minds
but hey i guess who can say something
good about brooks he didn't cross state
lines
welcome tonight's yes if
if you remember her from mtv you're old
enough for relief actor host of kennedy
on fox business kennedy
ladies he's recently divorced funny and
he can fly when he flaps his ears
comedian writer and actor jamie lissau
after she blew into a breathalyzer and
had to go to rehab fox news contributor
captain
and the big and tall store is really
just baby gap to him my massive sidekick
in the nwa is world television champion
paris
so jamie there's a lot of stuff going on
with this story but i have a feeling
you're more interested in the tweety
lady yeah lady that tweeted that it was
karma
yeah the tweety lady when i read her
tweet and then i saw that she was an
improv
actress i was like oh that's why they're
not funny yes and um
i don't mean to dump on like improv
people but you guys i dated someone that
was in an improv true point it was like
the worst relationship i've ever been
it's it's just unbelievably stressful
like i'd be like oh my god i'm so hungry
and she would go name a restaurant and i
would go
i would go japanese and we're like we're
in a japanese restaurant i'm like no
we're not i'm starving but it was good
in the bedroom because you're like can
we try this and she's like yes and
[Laughter]
i recommend if you ever go to an improv
group and they go give me an occupation
actually give them one
but she's no longer the media director
for the democrats that happened while
right before we were taping the show so
i would call that karma
in a strange way kennedy what do you
make of this uh bad timing or is it
is there any bad good timing with what
the squad's calling for on the day that
day after this happens whenever they
open their mouths and talk about
criminal justice reform as a libertarian
and cat will give me a what on this i go
this is why we can't have nice things
right because when you send dumb people
out to talk about really complex and
important issues they ruin it for
everybody because you can't say let's
empty out the federal prisons like it's
a cracker jack box because all the
investors who are guilty of white-collar
crimes they would be freed too
and if you did that the squad would lose
their minds there are smart ways of
doing things so you don't criminalize
behavior that is consensual things like
prostitution or certain drug
transactions people shouldn't be in
prison for those kind of things when you
beat up your baby mama and try and run
her over with a car that's attempted
murder you should be in prison for a
long long time when you're going to hurt
someone and try and take their life
there's a good chance you're going to
try and do that to other people those
are the kind of people potentially that
should be incarcerated there are many
many people in this country who
shouldn't be but i don't think anyone in
the squad is smart enough to make that
list that's actually trustworthy okay
everything you said seems like something
that cat they would have covered before
you do this it's like all right we're
gonna do this bail reform thing but we
shouldn't let out the really really bad
guys right we should only do this stuff
that's consensual whether it's it's sex
work or it's drugs but we shouldn't let
out any of the of the people that kill
each other you know that would be bad
but it's almost like they went forward
with this this idea of comprehensive
bail reform without ever even thinking
about what consequences might come
except except when they did they go yeah
people might die but this is better
yeah well because they think that they
just want to one-up each other all the
time i don't think that they're talking
to other people it's like okay well we
should they probably started their
candidate with like maybe a good idea
and they're like no
nobody in prison ever and all the other
ones don't want one of them to be the
most woke one yeah so then they just
have to say yes exactly and i'm
surprised that you know aoc didn't come
and say actually we should do it nine
years eight years and they just go dead
because that's what happens when you're
with your friends right you do dumb
you would not have
done if you weren't trying to impress
your friends this goes back to the one
we are dying of in these liberal cities
of a one-party system new york city we
can talk for days and weeks and years
about crime but it doesn't matter
because it's just a democratic party
that's all there is you don't they don't
have to change at all and bail reform
you can do whatever you want because
there's no republican party there right
no and again you people are scared to
say anything to them because they'll
they'll smear you as a racist in two
seconds yes saying you said the racist
thank you yes tyrus uh what are your
thoughts on this i can put a button in
all this i okay i've been
racking my brain trying to figure out
why
certain politicians in this case the
squad say the things they say and it all
just kind of came together right now i
got goosebumps they're improv
politicians
so
they go into a meeting
and they say give me a subject and
someone says prisons okay freedom okay
do we have money here no we'll take away
the money oh my god let's get this
passed that's how they're just they're
just winging it it just sounds good
in that interview she tried one of the
things that whenever has anyone ever had
a girlfriend friend who was lying to you
but they tried a sweet lie to you or
they like i'm having an affair with your
brother but they say it cute and having
an affair with your brother
and
it's wonderful and i'm sorry you have to
move out but because i said it's so
sweet you can't really get mad at me so
it's a lot of improv yeah a lot of
improvements are you yelling at me
hold on hold on none of your children
are yours let's take a break let's take
a break stop down and you try to compose
yourself and then we'll continue i did
wipe your bank account out
and i am sorry
so let's just think new house you moving
out
and it's cold
the other thing too is i well go ahead i
was just gonna say i know this bill is
like super controversial but it's
getting a ton of support from prisoners
i saw
across the board yeah there are like we
won't see any problem with it at all
exactly
all right we will we will stop on that